hey everybody John Luke here bringing
you PC gameplay of vanquish this is
running on Mac settings at over 60 fps
and the game has never run better if
you've never played vanquish we have a
feature about why the game is so darn
cool so make sure to check that out and
of course give us a sub enjoy your going
to be rendezvous in with friendlies
ahead spending over coordinates
understood problem move on
every day
learns look he's trying to lure suppose
I know that you want me to sacrifice and
tired me to help three men
no me do it you just keep your eyes up
my ass
have some too
enemy transmission nearing your position
[Applause]
enemy transport ship nearing your
position
you know I think that shock treatment
actually picks my backgrounds but you
get one of those things on eBay
this is gonna be fun
thanks sir I didn't think anyone was
coming for me
Thanks you saved the others yeah they're
already free their loss those bindings
felt great I don't believe this
the gate is opening there should be an
elevator on the other side y'all hear
that that's our ticket out get for the
elevator
you
[Music]
the gate is open there should be an
elevator on the other side you'll hear
that that's our ticket out get for the
elevator
we're Claire listen kalanadi
absent oohs hold still
administering epi have some juice
this will come in handy